a rookie police officer in Pennsylvania
has been charged with voluntary
manslaughter in the shooting death of an
unarmed man Jonathan Rozelle II of the
South white house Whitehall rather
Township Police Department surrendered
to authorities yesterday he is accused
of killing Joseph Santos last month
after responding to a call outside an
Allen town amusement park Nicky batiste
has reaction from the victim's family
and joins us at the table Nicky good
morning good morning officer Rose
Ellie's attorneys say their client
believes his actions late last month
were justified and appropriate but
yesterday a Pennsylvania prosecutor
disagreed now Joseph Santos family says
it wants answers and most of all justice
as long as we have air in our lungs we
will fight for Joey outside a
Pennsylvania courthouse Tuesday arlene
Figueroa reacted to the charge against
the 33 year old officer who killed her
daughter's father you murdered him his
hands were up in the air cell phone
video captured South Whitehall Township
Police officer Jonathan Rozelle II shoot
Joseph Santos on July 28th reporter bail
jumping on cars
Roselli was responding to calls about a
man acting erratically near an amusement
park this video shows the 44 year old
New Jersey man hanging onto a moving car
when Rosa Lee arrived Santos jumped on
the hood of his patrol car
Santos who was unarmed later walked
toward Rosalie's car again Roselli
ordered him to get on the ground but
Santos refused and Roselli fired five
shots officer vesali stated to the first
responding officer that he thought quote
Lehigh County District Attorney Jim
Martin said Roselli who joined the force
in December had pepper spray a baton and
stun gun on him at the time of the
shooting in my opinion this was the act
of a relatively inexperienced officer I
have concluded that he did not have to
discharge his weapon
Roselli is an Army veteran who served in
Afghanistan and is a major in the US
National Guard his attorneys say Roselli
believes evidence will show the shooting
was justified if convicted Roselli could
spend up to 20 years in prison
all right video is hard to watch yeah
that's our top story thanks Nikki